- You were talking about the
"Royal Rumble" coming up.
So explain that to everybody
who doesn't know what that is?
- So the "Royal Rumble",
it's a, it's a PLE of ours.
It's one of the biggest ones of the year.
It's one of our favorite ones.
- Yes.
- It jump starts the
road to "WrestleMania".
- [Montez] Yes.
- [Bianca] So it's unpredictable.
I, I always like to
describe it as a mixture
between the past, the
present, and the future.
And what it is, is 30 women in one ring.
It starts out with two
women in every two minutes
or so, another woman comes out
and no one knows who it's going to be.
So it's very...
- [Kelly] Oh, I like that.
- Unpredictable.
It can be a legend, someone from the past.
It can be a current superstar.
It could be one of the women from one
of the developmental programs
that's considered the future.
- It could be Kelly
Clarkson. - [Kelly] Okay.
- [Bianca] It could be anyone, exactly.
- You don't want me in that ring.
- [Bianca] It could be anyone.
- I got a lotta inner rage.
(audience laughing)
You don't want, you
don't wanna unleash this.
You gotta harness it in music.
- There you go.
Might see Kelly Clarkson
at the "Royal Rumble".
But the way to eliminate someone,
you throw them over the top rope.
So you, you're trying to throw
people over the top rope.
People are trying to throw
you over the top rope
and the way you win is you're
the last woman standing.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Bianca] And if you're
the last woman standing,
then you get an automatic
title match at "WrestleMania".
So it's a huge deal.
It's one of my favorites.
I actually won the "Royal
Rumble" the year that I got
to main event "WrestleMania".
So it changed the whole
trajectory of my career.
I won an ESPY off of that match.
So it's an exciting time of the year.
It can change someone's career.
It can change their
whole entire trajectory.
It's just an amazing match to watch.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Super exciting.
- I love the drama of
not knowing who's coming.
- Yes.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- For someone who doesn't watch-.
- Like Christmas dinner, when
people are bringing dates.
(audience laughing)
- [Montez] Exactly, right?
- [Kelly] Like, who will it be?
- Who will it be this year?
- [Kelly] Will they make it?
(audience and guests laughing)
- Alright, we have to do
a quick commercial break.
You can see WWE "Royal
Rumble 2024", January 27th,
exclusively on Peacock
and also "Love & WWE: Bianca
& Montez" is streaming
on Hulu from February 2nd.